previously on chef out of water what am
i going to do with a blindfold going on
a trip
oh god
i think i'm ready
[Music]
welcome to the season finale of chef out
of water i'm alexis your chef who's
always up for a challenge all season
long the internet has been choosing what
i should cook with and today it looks
like you've chosen where i don't know
who i'm cooking for and they don't know
what i'm cooking with although i'm
guessing they'll probably be able to
figure it out i can smell pine needles
and i hear a babbling brook
so
[Music]
oh my god
this is amazing this is my dream
all season long i've been asking for
fire and
i'm gonna have fire and i'm outside
thank you
so i'm gonna make a three-course meal
over campfire i've got to get some
kindling to get started let's go make a
fire
you thought you had me with a campfire
but this is actually a gift
i've been making fires for truly as long
as i can remember i grew up in the
country we have a really big fireplace
and every single night in the winter we
build a fire because it's so cold i
usually put a bunch of newspaper
crumpled up ton of kindling on top
luckily we're in the woods we have an
abundance of kindling and then make
like a kind of teepee situation around
it with the wood
and as soon as it gets hot then you can
add more wood and kind of shift it into
you know having some having direct heat
some having lower heat so i'll have some
more control over the campfire i have a
grate to cook with which is making it so
i don't want to say easy but
before i light this fire we need to talk
fire safety we've been working with the
angeles national forest they know we're
filming here there's a ton of people on
fire watch i've got ryan with me
he's gonna be watching the fire making
sure there's no debris anything
happening let's light this fire
my confidence level is a 10 right now
while my fire is going and getting
really hot getting ready i'm going to
start on dessert i'm making a plum
cardamom orange crumble i did a tasty
101 about this so i feel very prepared
so i'm starting off with some plums
did i seriously just play salt
i cannot be trusted
what is wrong with me was that solid
yeah it was literally just salt
oh no oh no
i'm going to go wash these plums off
stand by
i have to stop doing that
i also just said a minute before that i
was level 10 confident so i think i need
to bring my ego down about five notches
and stay away from salt
sugar
great
some flour as a binder you could use
cornstarch too orange zest i'm just
mixing everything together
the plums can actually just hang out in
this skillet
okay moving on to the filling i've got
flour
oats
salt intentionally
sugar very intentionally cinnamon
and cardamom
mix
and then some cold cubed butter
and i'm just going to take my hands
incorporate it and then kind of crumble
it you know i think a challenge is going
to be that i know how long this takes in
an oven or even on a grill but over a
campfire it's going to be a little
trickier in terms of timing
crumble's done i'm going to wash my
hands cover this with foil and get this
on fire got these really great safety
gloves this fire is really hot campfires
can actually get up to over 500 degrees
so i've got a ton of options it's
probably too hot for the crumble now but
i want to get it going the flames are
going to die down a bit
it actually looks like it's at the
perfect
spot for my entree i've got a few
different elements but one of them is
fire roasted eggplant where you actually
just bury it in the coals i'm going to
get a head start doing that move on to
my prep
for my appetizer the zucchini and
halloumi salad all done over the grill
of course when i used the blender i
thinly sliced zucchini on a mandolin so
i'm going to do the same thing they'll
probably grill really fast but that's
okay i'm just gonna sprinkle them with
little salt this is gonna draw
moisture out
just gonna slice cucumbers
easy
[Music]
i'm gonna make some pickled red onions
over the fire pickling's really easy you
basically need vinegar sugar and salt
oh and water
i'm gonna add some peppercorns
and some coriander seeds
so now this this liquid is gonna go over
the fire i'm just gonna cut up this
cheese really really fast
ooh baby
oh my god
cobbler has been taken over by the plums
but it's okay
okay definitely
time for tin foil to come out got my
pickling liquid which can go on the
hottest part
that right here
i'm just gonna let this go for a few
minutes and
my eggplant looks absolutely perfect i
mean
just falling apart it's like legit
collapsed into itself which is exactly
what i want
got a new set of
dish gloves
oh my god
so cool
and you just take a spoon
and all that beautiful perfectly cooked
eggplant
off the skin it goes inside my pickling
liquid is ready to go i'm gonna add the
onions
so now that the onions are in and the
pickling liquid is hot i can actually
take it off the heat and i'll just let
it rest to room temperature
this cobbler is definitely taking longer
than it would in an oven but it looks
kind of cool and rustic i'm just gonna
throw some peppers on the grill
i'm really excited about my entree i'm
gonna do this whole mediterranean spread
so i'm gonna make lamb kofta which are
like oblong lamb meatballs first things
first i'm gonna put garlic in the grill
too just a little bit of olive oil
wrapping it up you can just stick this
literally right in the fire gonna work
on the lamb kofta
so i've got mint
parsley
salt
cumin
some smoked paprika
oh i've got everything in my bowl for my
lamb kofta and then just gonna mix it
all together
my peppers are
so charred so beautiful oh my god i'm
just gonna peel the charred skin right
off i was hoping that the crumble was
gonna turn golden brown it's definitely
cooked through it's just doesn't have
that classic color it's also getting
kind of jammy on top like this jammy
plum mask um so i'm gonna take it off i
think it's fine it's not gonna be an
oven crumble but it's baked room it'll
be delicious you don't want to shape
these into
meatballs you want to make them into
these like oblong
an extra large egg maybe a duck egg
i'm just gonna skewer it my coughs are
done i have a bit more prep to do but
i'm gonna have ryan put them on the
grill ryan
you rang
if you can just put these over the grill
medium high heat okay sounds good this
is the best
i'm gonna add some lemons
the lemons i just want them to get
really charred and beautiful i'm gonna
use that for the baba ganoush and for a
vinaigrette i'm gonna make this kind of
garlic herby spread i'm gonna grab the
garlic out of the fire the garlic is a
bit charred it's soft it's just gonna
add a really nice smoky flavor to the
whole spread
just smashing it
and i'm just gonna make it into kind of
like a
paste a few pepper flakes i'm gonna add
some green olives i'm gonna add some
capers
just to add a little more brininess i'm
gonna hit it with some olive oil and i'm
gonna add salt to
a stir
i'm going to let this urby situation
hang out
these are good
they smell absolutely incredible they
look like they're cooked perfectly so
we'll see when she tries them
look at those lemons i'm just gonna move
them here
these zucchini are super thin so i
imagine it's gonna take less than two
minutes if that
halloumi
just at the bottom halloumi is a really
firm cheese
so
it's pretty ideal for grilling taking
lemons
oh great
they're just slightly charred which is
what i want i don't want them to fall
apart just have a little smokiness from
the grill
yeah the cheese is melting at a very
fast pace
okay no come on little guy oh hey
my confidence level on the salad is like
a nine
i'm gonna put ryan on fire watch fire's
nearly out and get everything assembled
now that everything's grilled i have a
few more things to do i'm gonna actually
have before the fire goes down i'm gonna
have ryan just grill these quickly ryan
this is the best way to cook i'm gonna
add
some of the lemon juice to my herby
thing
oh my god
it's so good
okay
wow the grilled garlic and grilled
lemons just intensify the flavors even
more got my eggplant from earlier
i'm gonna add some tahini lemon again
i'm gonna add a bit of salt
olive oil
oh my god
this is definitely the best campfire
meal i've ever made for the peppers see
how they've kind of collapsed into
themselves they have this amazing
charred skin and you can just peel it
right off that's the joy of a charred
pepper i thought maybe i'd make like a
platter a tray let's see how that goes
course two mediterranean plate is done
so now i'm just gonna plate this salad
let's add some mint
the onions have probably been pickling
for probably two or three hours but
after an hour you can use them
tiny bit of olive oil
a little bit of sumac
and
salt
this is so pretty i'm so happy my taste
tester has arrived and i think staying
in line with the campfire theme i'm
gonna serve the crumble just in the cast
iron i think it's time for them to taste
hi i'm hitomi i am a nifty producer here
at buzzfeed and i am a huge outdoor
enthusiast i
used to be a marine biologist i love
camping usually on the weekends i try to
find some fun things to do outside i'm
super excited to see what alexis uses
today because we are outdoors and you
know there's so many options now they
have solar ovens you have these small
little stove top ovens so there's so
many things but i know what she's going
to make is going to be amazing so i'm
super excited i think this was my
favorite day of the entire season and
it's the taste test i'm most excited for
so can we bring them in
i'm so excited oh thank you for having
me the perfect taste tester yay i think
you are the biggest outdoors person i
know oh thank you i mean
you go skiing you go camping you go
hiking you do everything oh
yeah well i'm very excited to be here
course one your appetizer
is a zucchini and halloumi
it smells good what does it smell like
to you
like summer but that i feel like summer
smells like barbecue and charcoal and
it definitely comes out of course too
this whole mediterranean spread this is
like insane over the top for at a
campsite
having this come out
i'm glamping like this
i'm glamping right now
yeah that's the move one of these a
mediterranean taco
wow that looks really good
is it good
can i okay i'm gonna do the same
[Music]
and this lemon grilled lemons are
great for anything like i bet it would
be great did you use this here
okay final course oh
beauty it is i know it looks crazy it's
a plum cardamom crumble
it's almost like a if a lemon tart
was a plum tart like the same
consistency totally you need a curd a
plum curd
totally that's exactly what it tastes
like this is so good these are the kind
of unexpected things that happen
when you're camping and now you have
this like whole new masterpiece that you
could be like yeah i made a plum tart a
plum curd it's a new thing
so tommy you've probably figured it out
by now but
what do you think i made this meal with
firewood right
yeah yeah it's firewood
you could smell it in the food i wish
you guys could smell it because you
could smell that like that wood burning
grill the char yeah there's nothing else
like it there's no appliance there's no
tool there's nothing else except
firewood and campfire that can give you
those flavors thank you thanks for
trekking up here and now we're into the
woods i love it this is like the best
work day ever so thank you so much
what an amazing season i feel proud of
myself i feel
excited i feel creatively inspired
honestly i didn't know that i could do
half of this stuff and
it was great campfire cooking was great
blender easy bake oven i just i feel so
lucky that i got to do this thank you
internet for all your suggestions your
tips your advice
and
even some of your crazy ideas i'm alexis
thanks for watching the first season of
chef out of water let me know in the
comments if you've made any crazy
campfire meals i'd love to see
[Music]
you